Mi seguro, siguiendo, administrator, en ese bosque, todo molino, aquí hay fotos, todos
hay aquí.
Ustedes ven las fotos del molino, todo.
Y ese muchachito pobre, como yo he explicado antes, logró, yo estoy contando, en 36 comprar
toda esa riqueza de 36 ocios, 700 hectáreas tierra con bosque, molino muy grande, usted
no sabe que es molino, que es harina, una cerradera, que entra el tapo, que hace tablas.
Ese muchachito, en 36, compró toda riqueza y pagó todo por estos 36 mil dólares, 36
mil dólares en el año 36, era como hoy, mínimo 100 mil dólares, el valor, de todo
que yo compro.
¿Qué edad tenía usted en ese momento?
En 36 de 12, ¿cuántos años tenía?, 24 años.
Gente se preguntaron, ¿cómo tú existes?, me dijeron, ¿cómo existes?, yo solo no sé.
Yo solo manejaba, mire, sin aviones, sin taxi, sin teléfonos, 300 obreros, que te
muestro dos, tú dices que eran dos obreros, cuando yo me fui en el 93 a ver mi molino,
mi cerradera, mi toda esa riqueza, quedaron dos obreros de 300.
Yo no dormía en la noche y no comía en el día, trabajaba más, como dice aquí,
que un burro, todo estaba dominado conmigo, ya mi hermano se era casado, otro hermano,
que dale, que mataron cuatro veces antes de la guerra, él estaba me ayudando.
¿Y los otros hermanos dónde estaban?
Casados, uno estaba enviado a Podlaska, y 33 hermanos mayores que estuve aquí, vinieron a Venezuela.
¿Por qué vino a Venezuela?
¿Por qué?
Porque aquí en 1930 vinieron sus cuñados, y él por su traducción...
No quiero, dice, ese asunto yo no quiero explicar, no quiero explicar.
Él vino para Venezuela.
¿Por qué?
Mis padres, seguro que descansan, que duermen.
Hay mi salvador, mío, que se murió cerca de cinco bolívares por ese árbol.
Y mi señora, como se le llama, estaba en Varsovia, estudiando en Varsovia.
Y mi mamá murió, tenía que regresar a la casa, era la única hija,
para ella papá era un dios, que no es de esa clase de gente que soy.
Y yo, siguiendo...
Cuando vino el fracaso, en el año 33, que le dijo usted,
Eiber, estaba casada con mi prima, fracasó por completo,
adonde mi mamá empeñó su cadera de oro.
Mi hermano, Guidaldo, más joven que yo, estaba casado con la hija de él.
Entonces él vino, hablado con el hermano mío, que yo ayudó a él.
Pues tiene tres hijas, un hijo, y perdió todo.
El hermano vino a hablar conmigo,
dijo, ¿qué quiere tu mejor? ¿Qué quiere su suegro?
Quiere que hacemos una sociedad.
Una sociedad pequeña,
hacer tablitas para impecatar huevos exportados para Alemania.
A Alemania les gustan mucho los huevos.
Entonces, yo no pienso mucho en los negocios.
Ok.
Cinco mil dólares.
¿Sabe que en Polonia poco existían cheques y bancos?
Era un solo banco.
Toma.
Cincuenta por ciento yo con mi hermano y él cincuenta por ciento.
Me hicieron eso.
El tiempo corre.
Yo no me culpaba de eso.
Yo no me quise sacar ganancia de esto.
¿Qué crees?
Después viene,
dice el mayor,
aquí hay un señor que se llama Korolowicz.
Él tiene una cerradera.
Vamos a comprar esa cerradera.
Como es mi profesión,
¿cuánto quiere? ¿Tanto? ¿Tanto? Ok.
Voy a comprarla.
Heiko Lovitz, eres ciego.
Los años corren.
Empezó el amor con mi señora.
¿En qué año comenzó el amor con su señora?
Treinta y siete.
¿Cómo se llama ella?
Estela Reis de Banshtok.
Como está escrito allá.
Y te voy a decirte una cosa
que puede ser que a usted le va a interesar en la vida.
Unas palabras.
Usted sabe que el viernes de la noche
hay una canción.
Seguro que usted sabe.
Shira, shira.
Ángel y Shloyman.
Y dice, ¿qué hay de mí, mi chico?
Es porque doy de mi viejo.
Él dice en su decía a Shira,
primero échale agua en tu jardín.
¿Qué te queda?
Échale en el jardín del vecino.
Cuanto él necesita.
De esto podemos hablar mucho horas y cosas.
Estoy dejando eso.
Usted quiere saber
qué es amor.
Usted puede coger un ejemplo
de Yaacov y Raquel.
¿Sabe qué era Yaacov?
¿Sabe qué era Raquel?
¿Cómo se enamoró Yaacov y Raquel?
¿En qué forma?
No sabe usted.
Raquel
era un muchacho muy pobre.
Era pastor.
Y tenía muchas ovejas.
Entonces, no es.
Hoy como usted
habla en la casa,
te llega agua, ¿no?
Tenía que sacar
del pozo agua.
Llegar.
Él no había hecho
una cosa.
Échale agua.
Y de allá tomaron
las ovejas.
Las ovejas tomaron agua.
Entonces se acercó
Yaacov
ayudando a sacar
el agua del pozo.
Cuando ambos
no se le habían encarado la cara,
pues la cara de Raquel
era
espejo de agua.
Como él la vio a espejo de agua,
ella se enamoró de él.
Ahora usted se va a preguntar,
mi amor.
La verdad
era un muchacho
que estudiaba muy poco
en Talmud.
Yo era frente
a la familia de mi señora
como un
hombre.
Y mi suegro
quiso para su hija
un
que estaba rebellioso,
que estaba rabino,
que estaba macho en Talmud.
Esto llegaba hasta la historia, mire.
Entonces era
un muchacho joven
a piso de muerte.
Yo salía paseando con él
a la noche.
Mi suegro no lo sabía.
Él cuidando.
¿Cuántos años?
Cuidado.
La noche era
mi cuerpo moría en febrero,
más frío que hay en Polonia.
¿En qué año?
En 1938.